the war in ukraine is affecting all
aspects of life including sport but the
football league suspended after the
invasion ukrainian club shakhtar donetsk
have begun a series of charity games
they're calling the global tour for
peace their first matches took them to
greece and poland and today they're
playing in turkey the games aim to raise
money for ukraine's military and help
people displaced by the war
a moment goes by
when mikola matvienko isn't thinking
about the war back home in ukraine
even here on the training field in the
turkish city of istanbul
but your brain seems to tell you that in
fact you can't do anything
and the only thing you know how to do
that can help the country
is playing football
matvienko and shakhtar donetsk have had
to run from bombs before in 2014
fighting between government forces and
pro-russian separatists broke out in
eastern ukraine
shakta stadium the donbass arena was
badly damaged by shelling
so just so yeah as a young boy i often
went to the donbass arena and it was my
biggest dream to play at this wonderful
stadium for shakhtar donetsk but then
the war started and we left
since then shakhtar has led a nomadic
existence
they first fled to western ukraine
then east again to harkeef
eventually the capital keefe became
their new home
that's where mikola matrienko was when
the russian invasion began on february
24th
even today i can't believe that this has
happened
i felt so worried because i didn't know
what to do
you feel so empty because you realize
that your people are suffering
it's very hard
now shaktar is on the move again
although ukrainian men of military age
are currently required to stay in the
country mikula and his teammates were
given special government permission to
leave in early april
here in istanbul they are now preparing
for a series of friendlies all over
europe to raise awareness and money for
the war effort in ukraine
the first friendly match was in greece
against olympiacos
what unites us as a team is more than
football we share a common tragedy
we wore t-shirts with the names of the
cities that were attacked by the russian
army
the whole world should know the names of
these cities
special operation
i've always dreamed of living in ukraine
and i believe that it's still possible
i hope that peace will soon return to my
country
doesn't know when that might be
he currently doesn't even know where his
team will be training next month
but he says he won't give up on his big
dream
to play football again one day
back home in ukraine in the donbass
arena
[Music]